- Man just a few days til
that Game of Thrones premiere.
- Yeah I was just thinking
it's been nearly two years
since the last season,
isn't that crazy?
- Oh, it feels like
just yesterday,
I remember that show
like the back of my hand.
- Oh totally, the dragons.
- Oh yeah and then last
season when that one guy
was like, I didn't
think he was gonna die
and then he died
- he died, yeah.
(laughs)
yeah, the weddings,
- There was eggs right,
there was a dinosaur.
- There was the um.
- Can I be honest, I don't
remember what the ****
happened in this show.
- I don't remember
anything, I've seen 'em all.
- It's out.
- And I want to catch
up but what do we do?
- Do we just start
from the beginning.
- Right.
- Refresh our memory.
- Right it was seven seasons.
- No commercials.
- That's true.
- It's 67 hours.
- That's easy.
- I've got that kind of time.
- Oh yeah let's do it.
(dramatic music)
- Is that Tywin or Tyrion?
- I don't ****ing know I
thought you were keeping track
of the Lannisters.
How is this season one,
this is so much back story,
I don't even understand
what's going on.
We should just treat
it like a test.
- Right.
Like we're in school.
- Cram.
Pop quiz, where
is the Iron Bank?
- Winterfell?
- Are you asking me?
Or are you telling
me? Seriously, I need
someone to tell me!
I don't ****ing know!
Goddamn it, what would
help is if we came up
with like a rhyme that
helped us remember
what each character
does, like Cersei.
- Yes, yes, yes, like
Cersei shows no mercy.
- Melisandre.
- Melisandre, Melisandre,
has no dandruff.
I don't know why I said that.
- What was that, none
of them have dandruff.
- Right.
- What if we did a shot
every time someone got naked.
(snaps)
- Super smart.
(claps)
(laughs)
- Oh ****, that's a ****.
- I don't remember there
being this much nudity.
- No.
(dramatic music)
- I need a nap Paul.
- Only 43 more episodes left.
Alright you know what,
we need a little pick me up.
- Okay.
(clicks tongue)
- Check it out.
(laughs)
- Man I've never done a drug
in my life I can't do coke.
- Come on man
Don't you care about the
season eight premiere
of Game of Thrones?
Everyone's gonna be
talking about it.
There you go.
Winter is coming.
(snorts)
- I don't know Grandma,
maybe this time you have
to figure out how to find
your own insulin, huh?!
Whoa what's going on with you?
- Oh nothing my wife just
texted my kid just said
his first word, oh my
god, purple wedding,
my favorite episode come here.
I told you this
was gonna be fun.
You see all you have to do is
trust me, here have a drink.
Drink up.
(screams)
- Why did you say this
is your favorite episode?
- I don't know, the acting?
(yells)
- You're trying to
poison me, aren't you.
(shatters)
and what's this, hmm?
- It's my great
grandfather's chair why?
- Maybe I want to sit in it.
- You can't.
- I will.
- You won't, **** you, it's
my birthright, it's my claim!
- Wait a second wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait,
what are we doing,
we only have a few hours
to go, we can do this.
- You're right, so oh my god,
where did I go there, okay.
- I'm sorry.
- You know what, let's do this,
- [Both] Together.
(dramatic music)
(screeches)
- We did it, we did it, (laughs)
I cannot believe we did it.
- I can't, wow.
- 67 hours actually
went by really quick.
- It did actually, wow.
- We've still got a
couple hours to spare.
- You thinking
what I'm thinking?
- Big Little Lies.
- Let's do it.
- Alright.
Binge it.
(upbeat music)